hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my arrow flash crossover part
one video just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet they
did a whole bunch of legends of tomorrow
set up as well as a bunch of flash stuff
because this was the flash episode part
two of the crossover will be on arrow so
they'll be dealing with some extra arrow
things so expect some damian darhk--
stuff happening too like there was the
self-contained story setting up Vandal
Savage for this episode but then they
each have their continuing storylines
like they have Barry versus Zhu they
have team arrow versus damian darhk--
also going on in the background
moo-coo reminder new round of the
reverse flash ring giveaway starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so I'm gonna do top 10 WTF just
cuz there's so much stuff so I'll try to
explain Easter eggs as I go along
starting with number 10 Harrison wells
has a special formula that he's going to
try and use on Barry to push him faster
in the comics there's a formula called
velocity 9 that edward clariss
the very first reverse flash ends up
making to try and make himself as fast
as Jay Garrick he becomes that eras
reverse flash as a result of taking the
serum on the TV show it's called
velocity-6 now Andrew Kreisberg the
showrunner said that we would see future
iterations of this he'll probably get to
velocity 9 through the back half of the
season but he said the mystery is gonna
be who ends up taking the serum because
Jay Garrick is all about keeping it away
from Barry speaking of which onto number
9 Jay Garrick comes back he's been gone
for a while saves Harrison wells they
have a moment so they're not best
friends or anything but we know that the
serum will work if Jay takes it again so
maybe if they were fine it Jay takes
more of it the effects will last longer
but I think the way Jay reacted to this
definitely throws some water on the
theory that he might be zoom he was
never my favorite on like the list of
people that could possibly be zoom but
there were some moments in earlier
episodes where you could argue that he
you know he was acting really strange
like he was never around when zoom was
around but we did see that sequence with
them at the beginning of the season so I
do think that Jay Garrick is not zoom
under number 8 though patty shoots
Harrison wells this is so great like oh
my god what did you do so a couple big
things happening here a lot to unpack
one Patty has absolutely no idea what's
going on with earth 2 what team flash
has been doing Joe hasn't told her
anything
Caitlin does not know that so when she
says call Joe get his help I'm guessing
there's going to be some ramifications
Asians in the second part of this
crossover episode we're Paddy's like
dude seriously what the hell is going on
that kind of gets into like what's going
on with Barry and Paddy like is he gonna
tell her his secret what's going on with
that that's like a completely separate
matter but it all ties together like
people being dishonest with other
characters the same things happening
with iris West knowing about Wally West
but not telling Joe on the number seven
enter Vandal Savage who doesn't look
quite as powerful as he does in the
legends of tomorrow trailer but they do
explain that every time he kills Hawkman
and Hawkgirl he gets a little bit
stronger his life force grows as a
result of killing them I don't know if
they said specifically how many times
he's killed them as of right now like
where we are in the timeline right now
it's probably been a lot I think in
legends of tomorrow that future they're
trying to avoid it's implied that Vandal
Savage is almost invincible Cisco barely
manages to get a Highlander reference in
before they all go to Star City because
Barry feels like this is a magical thing
that they don't know anything about they
get there just in time for Barry to save
Oliver from damien darhk's powers now I
guess Oliver's tattoo is gonna figure in
much later maybe it'll save him from
Vandal Savage
but the Constantine tattoo will be
important later to this season but I
love the way damian darhk-- reacts to
the flash like oh my god this is so
amazing I can't believe this it's the
greatest thing ever I totally love with
that actors doing with that character he
also slips in one of my favorite jokes
did I know that we knew the flash I
guess yeah we know the flash scenes like
this are really good for reminding you
which characters know which other
characters secrets not not everybody
knows everything
Cisco says that he could come up with a
better name than speedy for her she
doesn't want to change it but let me
know what you think Cisco would rename
speedy if he had the chance because she
already teased red arrow Dolliver and he
shut her down hardcore so obviously it
wouldn't be that but onto my number six
WTF enter Merlyn I love what a
theatrical entrance they give him like
the lights flash and he's just like
surprise he's the one that
explains Vandal Savage not not in great
detail because that's what Hawkman ends
up doing later
he just says this guy is immortal
there's no way you're gonna be able to
beat him we're gonna need a lot of help
he's just there to let them know that
Vandal Savage has been around for all of
human history he predates the League of
Assassins which is itself in ancient
culture
number five WTF though hawkman to the
rescue just swoops in grabs Kendra and
takes off he's been in a bunch of
trailers but this is the first time he's
actually been in an episode if you
haven't watched the animated series
there's been a bunch of versions of
Hawkman on the screen like the last
live-action version of the character was
played by Michael Shanks during
Smallville that was like the older
version of Hawkman after Hawkgirl had
already died so like imagine much older
versions of these characters but he
explains that Hawkgirl has not emerged
like her powers have not emerged in this
life yet so she has to do the thing that
Barry did believe in herself let go of
all the baggage and just jump
off the building
Cisco tries like really hard to hold on
to her and I know that they have this
this romance that they've been teasing
between them but does anybody else feel
like this is a little artificial like
they had that thing with golden glider
like he felt really connected to her but
then like just like a couple weeks later
he was all over Hawkgirl it kind of
feels like the only reason that Cisco
relationship exists is to create the
drama of this moment right here give her
character a reason to want to be normal
like all the characters have superhero
things that they do like using their
powers fighting villains and then they
have the normal stuff like normal stuff
for Barry is when he's hanging out with
Patty then there's all the time he's
acting as the flash defeating villains
using his powers so I think the Cisco
thing is just meant to be like the
normal stuff for Hawkgirl so she'll have
like Hawkgirl mode then she'll have
Cisco mode when she's just like being
normal with Cisco but this is the CW
it's all about love triangles so of
course you have Hawkman we've been
lovers across space and time so I think
her whole thing with Cisco there's where
she's like me you know maybe things are
holding me back I need to embrace my
destiny it just means that she's gonna
go off and be on legends of tomorrow and
she'll just continue to think of Cisco
fondly but I'm not expecting any crazy
romance stuff between the two of them so
if you're not really down with that
don't worry and I don't think they're
gonna beat you over the head with it
Tonto my number 4 WTF Hawkman explains
their origin story with Vandal Savage so
this is a big change from the comic book
so they're a bunch of Easter eggs for
Hawkman Vandal Savage origin stories it
kind of gets into legends of tomorrow
stuff but you see the meteor here
getting ready to strike the pyramid and
it looks like it happens around the same
time that Vandal Savage kills Yara or
Hawkgirl Hobbie want to think about it
for the first time with one of the nth
metal daggers now I don't know
they're gonna call this mineral enth
metal but that's basically what it is in
the comics the reason that hawkman and
hawkgirl keep getting reincarnated is
because a character named hath-set who's
different from vandal savage ends up
killing them with nth metal daggers and
because of the magical properties it
curses them and begins the cycle of
death and rebirth like this constant
reincarnation
so when Vandal Savage says that he has
to like keep killing them to feed his
lifeforce that's like a half set story
vandal savage's origin story is all
about getting struck with a meteorite
that gives him immortality and evolves
his brain makes him super smart so what
they've done is they combined the meteor
origins of Vandal Savage with the nth
metal murder origins of Hawkman and
Hawkgirl and just tie those together
hopefully what they'll do in the second
part of the crossover is we'll see a
couple more flashbacks but I think
they're gonna push a lot of Vandal
Savage storyline two legends of tomorrow
and they did they announced the premiere
is gonna be Thursday January 21st I
believe so it'll be flash on Tuesdays
arrow on Wednesdays and then legends of
tomorrow on Thursdays but on my number
three WTF Vandal Savage gets the staff
of Horus this is just a really powerful
artifact there are a number of Horus
related artifacts in the DC Universe
there's the Eye of Horus which showed up
during Constantine's TV show last year
and then there's the claw of Horus which
Hawkman wears but you know maybe not on
the show and it's just part of Egyptian
mythology which gets tied up with
Hawkman Hawkgirl origin stories and for
those that are wondering when Vandal
Savage is speaking in a foreign language
that's a Gyptian
Arabic because I mean they're basically
saying like he's the hath-set character
so he's from ancient Egypt too but on my
number two WTF Hawkgirl
activates her powers so she has her
wings now it looks like part two of the
crossover is when Hawkman gives her her
armor now she's talking to Hawkman
through the episodes like she starts to
have flashes of her previous life so I
think she's gonna unlock her abilities a
little bit faster than say Barry does
because Barry doesn't know what it's
like to be the ultimate version of the
flash yet all Hawkgirl has to do is just
remember her previous life and she'll be
like oh I remember how to fly around I
remember how to do this but finally out
of my number one WTF
Oliver bumps into his son who is not
Connor Hawke I know everyone's wondering
about this because they posted a promo
where Oliver like goes up to the house I
did a video for it the other day so we
already knew that Oliver was gonna
find out that he had his son but he's
calling him William so there's one of
two things that could be happening it
could be like Thea
we're like Thea's name is Thea Dearden
Queen she is the Mia Dearden speedy from
the comics they could just be messing
with the connor hawke name a little bit
or this could just be a completely
original character of the show and yes a
lot of you guys have asked me do I think
that the son or the mother is gonna be
the person in the grave at the end of
the season the one that they teased I
don't necessarily think that's gonna be
the case I still think it's gonna be
there like Diggle or Quentin it's a long
ways off so we'll just have to see like
what happens with this son in the next
episode figure out where Oliver is gonna
go from here what might end up happening
is is we'll just see the child like once
a year during the special crossover
episodes you know like last year we just
got the tease they might do the same
thing once a year given the trajectory
of the Oliver character it seems like
he'd try to have a more normal
relationship with it but given his
superhero life he's probably gonna try
and keep him away like look my life is
very dangerous I don't want to get you
tied up in this but I would like to be
part of my son's life so let me know in
the comments below what was your guy's
favorite moment from the episode and who
do you think is gonna be taking the
velocity-9 formula in the future do you
think here so Welles himself is gonna
try and take it or anything that Jay
Garrick will cave and take it to try and
help Barry defeat zoom there's really
like so much going on and they haven't
even aired the promo for episode 9 yet
which is when we're gonna get to see
Wally West for the first time that's
like a whole other thing will have to
wait till next week to talk about we are
still in the thick of hawkman hawkgirl
origins there was a short promo that
they aired during the episode four
legends of tomorrow it had a little bit
of new footage but most of the stuff
we've already seen so like if you've
watched my trailer video for that then
you pretty much know what's going on so
what's gonna happen next there's some
really big stuff happening Wednesday
night there's a full Batman V Superman
trailer that's dropping that's gonna be
like way late in the night so I might
finish my arrow video before that posts
so generally just be aware that a bunch
of stuff is gonna be dropping tomorrow
night you can actually follow me on
Twitter and Facebook and I'll be posting
updates about when videos are coming if
you guys haven't seen it yet you can
click here for my Batman V Superman
teaser video and you can click here for
the legends of tomorrow trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight